[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
para ello ya está conmigo el estudio de
luís méndez luis bienvenido feliz
viernes para ti también vamos a comenzar
en eeuu porque el senado de ese país se
aprobó elevar el límite al denominado
techo de la deuda de raúl fue un tema de
preocupación durante varias semanas que
motivó largo debate dentro del senado
estadounidense pero ayer ya sobre la
tarde pudieron lograr un acuerdo para
entonces alcanzar esta noticia y que
ahora espera por la aprobación de la
cámara de representante este acuerdo
entre otras cosas evita el
incumplimiento de pago en las
obligaciones estadounidenses para las
próximas semanas como se sabe este
acuerdo permite que el límite de la
deuda se incrementen a 480 mil millones
de dólares con ello el departamento del
tesoro podrá hacer el pago de algunos
compromisos hasta el 3 de diciembre de
acuerdo con la publicación
estadounidense 100 bis y la deuda del
país actualmente gira en torno a los 20
84 billones de dólares y con el aumento
podría alcanzar los 28,8 millones
millones de dólares sobre ello la
secretaría del tesoro janet yellen
minutos después de haberse coordinado
esta aprobación en una conversación con
el canal 100 en que cita reuters señaló
que la situación respecto al techo de la
deuda ha hecho que tanto estadounidenses
como los mercados se cuestionen si el
país toma en serio lo que es el pago de
sus facturas ahora a louis seguimos
hablando de más economía vamos a europa
porque la república de irlanda anunció
que se suma al acuerdo de la ocde para
una fiscalidad internacional lo primero
que tenemos que tomar en cuenta es que
está este acuerdo internacional de la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico propone un momento
internacional de 15 por ciento para las
empresas
multinacionales en este sentido el
gobierno irlandés pone fin a su política
de baja fiscalidad que llegó en el año
2003 y que le ha permitido atraer una
gran cantidad de empresas
multinacionales especialmente aquellas
que están ligadas al sector tecnológico
en este sentido irlanda modificará su
tributo que va desde un 12 5 por ciento
15 ya mencionado el gobierno obviamente
estimó una caída en los ingresos debido
a esta modificación y la calculan por el
orden de los dos mil millones de euros
anuales sin embargo espera compensar
esta situación con el aumento de
impuestos a sociedades al conocerse a
las noticias ya varias personas han
relacionados y una de los organismos que
reaccionó fue la cámara de comercio de
irlanda que como dos de las empresas
acogió con satisfacción la noticia y en
el comunicado agrega que
intereses del país estarán resguardados
ya que el marco legal tributario y
regulatorio estaría en sintonía con el
derecho internacional luís también lo
hablamos en uno de nuestros programas
esta semana sobre la apertura de la
economía cubana pero es que ahora existe
la preocupación por el aumento a los
precios de los servicios turísticos
porque fue una situación que se
encontraron los usuarios y también los
dueños de algunos de estas empresas
sobre todo de servicios turísticos
porque han visto el incremento en los
precios esto de acuerdo con la agencia
de noticias efe para recordar que hace
aproximadamente dos semanas abrieron en
la nación caribeña este tipo de negocios
restaurantes bares y otros servicios
turísticos en ocho de las 15 provincias
de la nación pero ante los problemas
económicos los prestadores de servicios
se han expresado en contra de los altos
precios que como es habitual tienen que
trasladarlos a los consumidores y estos
por supuesto han mostrado su desacuerdo
básicamente a través de las redes
sociales pero escuchemos qué dicen los
propietarios de estos establecimientos
de acuerdo al incremento de los precios
si hoy la carne la suben yo tengo que
subir el precio porque la mayoría de los
insumos casi todos excepto del servicio
hay que pagarlos en dólares moneda
libremente convertibles entonces
gobierno no te da acceso a ese a esos
dólares entonces tenemos que comprar los
dólares para poder hacer los productos y
luego vender en moneda nacional a un
precio extra de súper súper keaton bien
es luís seguimos con más información le
pregunto por qué te es la mujer a sus
oficinas de el estado de california eeuu
básicamente un tema de espacio o raúl
una empresa que se fundó en silicon
valley alrededor de otras empresas con
capacidad para cientos de empleados ha
crecido a magnitud que hoy tiene miles y
deciden entonces ya no tener al no tener
espacio para el crecimiento trasladarse
de las ciudades de california en la que
se encuentra austin texas de esta manera
entonces este es la estaría mudando a
sus oficinas en los próximos meses para
poder desarrollar al máximo su capacidad
este fue un anuncio que hizo y los más
el día de ayer en una junta
louis gracias por toda esta información
económica nuestro primer bloque en
directo americanos debe las indicadores
y la cifra el día para más adelante
ahora vamos con nuestro reportaje del
día de básicos
[Música]